patents they're basically legally
binding dibs and they're important if
you invent something in American you get
it approved by the Patent and Trademark
Office the rights to that idea then
belong to you they're absolutely
essential to business as you would know
if you've ever seen an episode of shark
tank why aren't you telling you about
something proprietary or patent or a
technology or software no one can
emulate I hope you do get your patent
and I wish you good luck without having
it I'm feel that you're gonna really
have a struggle don't have a patent
don't have a finished sample don't have
experience unless you have a patent or
some proprietary technology you're gonna
be in trouble I'm out I'm out I'm out
exactly arriving on the set of Shark
Tank without a patent is like turning up
to America's Next Top Model without
knowing how to smize or booty tooch you
take that to catalogue you're not
editorial you're not editorial I don't
know what that means but the point is if
you don't have a patent you don't have a
prayer on Shark Tank
unless you've got a once-in-a-lifetime
investment opportunity like this guy um
you go to my site you describe a cat I
draw I'm a little sad I'd invest if I
were you and I want to draw a cat for
you
by the way his business got funded
presumably because he holds the patent
on whatever the he's doing with his
shoulders the problem is the patent
system has increasingly been prone to
abuse for instance a few years ago a man
named Austin Mayer made a popular flight
simulator app and then one day received
a frightening letter it said that a
company called yuna lock was filing suit
against me
the company is suing mayer for patent
infringement according to the lawsuit
yuna lock says it owns the idea of a
computer program checking a central
server for authorization it is the
technology upon which all android apps
are based all Android out that I know of
everyone I know of it's true this
company yuna lock is essentially
claiming it's entitled to a piece of
every Android app that technically means
they could show up at the headquarters
of tinder and demand a cut of everything
tinder has created which I assume would
be a pile of stds sad orgasms and shards
of human self-esteem that's that's the
business model but this this situation
has become so common there's even a name
for companies that do this so-called
patent trolls typically don't invent
anything or sell anything they simply
buy patents and make their money by
threatening lawsuits yet most of these
companies don't produce anything they
just shake down anyone who does so
calling them trolls is a little
misleading at least trolls actually do
something they control bridge access for
goats and ask people fun riddles patent
trolls just threatened to sue the living
out of people and believe me those
lawsuits add up in fact of the 4,700
patent lawsuits filed 2012 3000 were
from these so-called patent trolls the
White House claims during the last two
years the number of lawsuits brought by
patent trolls has nearly tripled
research shows this type of litigation
has cost investors an estimated half a
trillion dollars since 1990 half a
trillion let me put that in context to
lose other people that amount of money
Johnny Depp would have had to start in
the Lone Ranger
over a hundred
a year for 25 years that's our
horrifying amount horrifying and
Pancho's target everyone from big
businesses like Apple and Samsung to
tiny ones in fact you don't even need to
make something to be targeted you just
need to use something a business and all
line couldn't believe it when someone
threatened to sue them for using their
own copy machine we provide employment
services for people with barriers to
employment mostly people with
disabilities folder LLC threatened to
file unless Hurley forked over a
thousand dollars for each employee who
uses the scan to email function on this
copier vulner says it's entitled to this
licensing money because it owns the
patents for that process Wow when you
are threatening to sue a company which
helps people with disabilities find work
for using their own photocopier you're
not just on the road to hell
you have your own parking spot right
next to the devil so so how
exactly did we get ourselves into this
mess well in part it has to do with the
types of patents that have been issued
the Patent Office is supposed to certify
inventions that are new useful and
non-obvious incidentally all the
adjectives that Tom Cruise would say
he's seeking in an ideal mate but but
during periods a big technological
change they can get overwhelmed and
certified patents that they shouldn't
this happened in the 19th century with
railroads and then again more recently
with the development of software in the
last decade the number of software
patents has skyrocketed the issue here
say experts is that what patents from
machines tend to be fairly specific
software patents can be so broad and
vague that they may give someone the
ability to later claim ownership for
inventions they never dreamed of at the
time and that is the seed our current
problems because if a troll can get a
vaguely defined software patent they can
demand payment for anything that fits
that description basically if they
thought to patent computer things that
never works years ago they currently be
getting rich off of face time very very
rich
Pancho's have this process down to such
a science for a start they have figured
out a way to almost never go to trial
one study found that almost 90% of cases
are settled for a very practical reason
it's an extortion game because it costs
between two and five million dollars to
defend a patent suit so the patent troll
says we'll settle for a hundred thousand
many decide to pay out settlements
because it's cheaper than fighting the
lawsuits so they work out the maximum
amount of money you'd be willing to pay
rather than go to court and negotiate
for that they pick a number the same way
Airlines pick a cabin temperature
perfectly calibrated to make you
miserable but not so much that you'd
actually do anything about it and the
most frustrating thing is sometimes it's
hard to know who's behind all of this
they often have vague company names like
IP nav Empire IP or pragmatists and
incidentally pragmatist sounds like the
most boring mythological Greek hero of
all time
I am pragmatist and I shall not battle
the Hydra for it is much larger than me
so I shall go home via the farmers
market for the bruised vegetables are
cheaper at the end of the day pragmatist
bids you farewell
patent trolls controls I've even managed
to find the friendliest place to file
their lawsuits almost a quarter of last
year's US patent cases were filed in
this Eastern Texas federal court
district Marshall Texas population
24,000 a quarter of all patent cases are
filed in Marshall Texas and believe me
it is not because people there are
inventing like a meth head in a Home
Depot iron I combined a wheel with a
nail it's a nail wheel new invention
patent his four feet of PVC piping I can
use for a big strong patent holy
I'm a genius give me more meth Pancho's
have figured out that for whatever
reason East Texas judges and juries are
sympathetic to plaintiffs and it has
been so effective that big companies are
having to go to absurd lengths to pander
to the people of Marshall Texas tech
companies know the value of a good PR
campaign here Marshall we're almost
anyone could be on your next jury a city
official tells us that Samsung sued here
multiple times has spent almost a
million dollars on community projects
like this ice-skating rink right in
front of the courthouse
Samsung was so frightened of patent
lawsuits they felt forced to build an
outdoor ice rink in Texas do you know
how hard that is to maintain it's like
building a bowling alley in space this
situation is insane now the good news is
there is cross-party support in
Washington for fixing this problem in
fact a bipartisan bill was introduced
two years ago called the innovation act
with some decent ideas such as
encouraging judges to make patent trolls
pay court costs if they lose and forcing
patent trolls to be more transparent
about their identities and I'm not
saying that bill was perfect but it
would have helped it's like when parents
of teenagers lock the liquor cabinet
look I know this isn't going to stop you
Rhapsody but it will make it just a
little harder for you to cut the entire
neighborhood unfortunately while the
bill passed the House by an overwhelming
majority it never even made it to a vote
in the Senate I wonder why would that be
what do you make of the this bill
getting killed well I know this is news
but trial lawyers influence in
Washington is alive and well yes
apparently lobbyists for groups
including trial lawyers managed to
prevent the bill from moving forward and
you cannot let trial lawyers decide
whether there should be more baseless
lawsuits that's the equivalent of
trusting raccoons to make laws about
garbage can placements
they should be easy to reach and left
slightly open
all in favor say
Hey
that's a good impression as far as you
know luckily there was actually a
glimmer of hope here because that bill
is making the rounds again and look even
if it doesn't pass something has to we
have to do something or the only viable
business left in America is going to be
one that relies on no patents whatsoever
and I can only think of one business
that fits that description I'll try you
a cat whatever the vibe I draw the cat
that you described
I guess all I'm saying is hit it let's
reform our patents quick or we will all
be in the
you